like a lot of people you dealt with
Stage Fright I didn't know that at the
beginning I had no idea on any stage
fright I know you're very you're like
it's not that I'm it's not that I'm I
mean I'm a fair amount of confidence I
just mean like we're probably gonna
screw up though sometimes so like
whatever can be perfect yeah that's I
think I just have such a low bar
expectation
I'm like I mean I'm gonna do my best
like and I feel like you just you know
sometimes it happens and you you have
nights where you're like I did amazing
and you have nights where you're like
why am I yeah
no I think how did you know that I did
well it started more just because I was
singing in bars from the age of eight
years old very intimidating environment
and everybody's already drunk and
they're falling everywhere
yeah cigarettes you know it just wasn't
and I think it was more yes that's me
little bitty
but you know and so I I think I learned
very young to put on a front a mask of
like okay I you know I'm up here and I'm
professional yeah and I'm you know and
but I was petrified I was so
uncomfortable and I think it just stayed
with me
um
never really finding my comfort zone out
there for a long long time I'm in a way
better place now I don't know what
happened I think many things happened
but uh I grew up I guess
um
but very recently I'm much more
comfortable with it now I just see
things differently yeah um but whoa no
no for many many many many many years
until like I said very recently was
always very pet music I always feel so I
know a lot a lot of artists actually
struggle with that and I I'm like I
don't know if I'd go out on stage and do
it I think that you're brave if I ever
felt like that I don't think I would
follow through it's torture yeah it
really is torture to have that anxiety
and when I get nervous my stomach does
this thing where uh what would you get
well it's not like a bridesmaid scenario
it's like you know you're like oh my
gosh is this going to happen on stage
like your horse
like I get I'm just saying my stomach
when I get really nervous that's what
happened like I my stomach doesn't turn
yeah so what am I gonna do yeah no I
mean a lot of people do you know vomit
before they go on stage I know and I
know it's a reaction I I but I did learn
from a very young age the Mind Over
Matter you know put the mask on yeah out
there and and nobody should see that
you're
uh what you're really feeling so I was I
got good at that very young and managed
it but oh no
very scary feeling I'm glad you didn't
get it now because you're so awesome
live I think that's what's so awesome
about you is you're very welcoming like
you know I'm saying even if you're not
right talk about myth like welcoming
herself no I I think that that's very
that's what is so captivating you're
like even if you do mess up it's like
whatever everybody messes up I messed up
like 10 times today already like it
happens it's fine when you have to be
okay with that it's kind of like you
know the people that learn a language uh
more quickly are the ones that are not
afraid to make mistakes as they're
learning it otherwise you never you
never practice it out loud you never
um you know you're afraid to look stupid
or something no if it looks stupid you
have to be you have to really be ready I
mean and listen on stage if you hit the
wrong note you forget the words you do
look stupid but
your friends are there because they love
you and it's a mutual respect thing so
it's not every night it just happens
every once in a while that's why I guess
I don't I don't get it because I'm like
I'm I'm bound to suck a lot sometimes
like you know what I'm saying it's like
it's gonna happen so you do not you are
so great live you're amazing you're just
one of these in such incredible singers
of our time
I I Honestly though I think that's why I
like listening to you too is like it's
just listening to the artists that like
you're not doing it because you have to
you're doing because you love it and
there's a difference you know like
you're not doing it as because it's just
a job you sound like you love what you
do and you're all in like your whole
body I love that
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]